people become a victim of their own
success and then people want them to be
Bob Dylan or Brad Pitt or the CEO of you
know Google or uber or whatever it is
and they can't be anything else because
the public wants them to be that so
badly and then if it doesn't work out
you know and folk music goes away then
all of a sudden you're kind of the
bottom comes out from under you
definitely yeah you you can you can get
painted into a corner or paint yourself
into a corner that way and even if
you're not successful it's quite easy to
do that so by it by having sort of an
undefined set of skills now that doesn't
mean you don't focus I think that it'll
both you and I can we don't have to get
into it right now but I mean the power
if you look at sort of the power law
distribution of start-up returns it's
like yeah I mean they're gonna be one or
two that bring back everything and more
so there are there are times to double
down and really focus in one area but I
think that it's very easy for people to
get trapped into more so definitely
success but they start to view
themselves as their job title or as
their company and they immediately
closed off options they put on blinders
in a way that is unhelpful there are
helpful blinders and then there are
handicapping liners and you have to
learn to distinguish between the two